from somewhere deep within the vastness
of YouTube a man come
you
who the [ __ ] is that
I think it's me check it out
hello who is it hey this message coming
from the house of YouTube it's intended
for the right honourable Felix offered
off ok cell we're also known as
PewDiePie we wish to express our deepest
most profound probe ecology for the
delay of your diamond play button award
it was not how I wish this please you
are your formidable bro army this is why
we have provided you with your horse and
glitter and now for your Diamond play
button finally it's about damn time
the legends were true
it exists oh man oh so heavy
yes hi there
my precious cinnamon toes kick
you son-of-a-bitch how dare you show
your face around these parts I'm here to
claim what's mine diamond play button
get back here can you son of a [ __ ]
that's my play button no how could you
do this
bah how could this happen
YouTube have one nice wish
give me another play button now we'll
forgive your sins
yeah